[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAX SALTONSTALL: Hi.
I'm Max Saltonstall.
Welcome to Architecting
with Google Cloud.
Have you ever wanted to
know how those ads end up
inside your mobile
apps, inviting
you to install something else?
How does machine learning
work to figure out which ones
are the right ones to show?
I was pretty
curious, so I invited
Chang, VP of Engineering
at MOLOCO to join us.
Hi, Chang.
Welcome to the show.
CHANG KIM: Hi, Max.
Thank you.
I'm happy to be here.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Can you tell
me a little bit about MOLOCO
and what your role is?
CHANG KIM: MOLOCO is
a startup and then we
want to build and deliver the
world's best vertical Cloud
service for online advertisement
and marketing businesses
by helping them unleash their
data or the power of their data
using our AI and big data
processing technologies.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So I'm
using an app on my phone,
I see an ad inviting me
to install something else.
Can you walk me
through the lifecycle
of how that ad gets through
all of these systems
and ends up on my screen?
CHANG KIM: We start working
with our customers, who
are typically mobile app
development companies,
and then their marketing
teams come to us
and then commission their
advertisement campaigns
because they wanted
to sell their apps
or have more people use their
apps, install their apps,
engage with their
apps, and so on.
So that's their key goal that
they achieve through MOLOCO.
And when we receive these ad
campaigns, on the other hand,
we have lots of
mobile users out there
around the world, billions of
users using phones or typically
similar kind of form
factors, tablets and so on.
So whenever they use their
devices, some apps are running
and then these apps keep
creating the advertisement
slots.
So these are called ad
spaces or ad inventories,
and then we basically want
to field these ad inventories
by showing them the most
relevant and helpful
advertisement contents to them.
And to do that, we
need some matchmaking
and then this
matchmaking is done
through what we call the
advertisement exchanges or ad
exchanges.
These are similar to the stock
exchanges like NYSE and NASDAQ
where supply and demand meet
together and then arrive
at the right outcomes
through online bidding.
We receive these ad
inventories not directly,
but through ad exchanges.
And then whenever we
receive this bid request,
we quickly evaluate the
value of this ad space
relative to our advertisement
customers campaigns
and then we use a lot of big
data and machine learning
technologies to make a
decision on whether we
should participate in that
bidding or we should not.
And then if we're going to
participate, at what price
should we bid for?
Right?
So we make these quick
computations and decisions
and then when we respond,
again, back to the ad exchanges,
the exchanges collect
this information
and then run the
auction, online auction.
And then if we happen
to win, then we
own that particular ad space
that is created at that point
and then we show our customers
ads through that space.
So the unique thing
about this industry
and using ML for
this industry is
that we have to come up
with quality inference
result, but very timely as well
because think about the stock
exchange, right?
When you announce that
there is this supply,
the demand has to make
a bid very quickly.
In online ad, the
strictness of the time
is actually even harsher because
when you open a publishing app,
that ad slot doesn't
wait for you forever.
It's usually going to wait for,
say, about 100 milliseconds
or 150 milliseconds.
Within that or after
that, the proper ads
need to show up otherwise
it's considered a failure.
So when we receive these
bid requests through the ad
exchanges we have to make
that decision very quickly,
typically within
100 milliseconds.
And then that 100 milliseconds
includes networking latency
and our other infrastructure
latencies as well.
So the actual amount of time
that is left for ML inference
is actually even smaller.
It's typically about 20
milliseconds or even less
sometimes, but still we have to
make a very relevant prediction
about this particular
user and the content
and also we have to use many ML
models, not just one because we
have to guess the, say,
the user's interest
level about these
campaigns, many campaigns.
And then we have to predict
how likely the user is going
to use this app or they
respond to the advertisement
and then use the
new app over time
and then create even
more lifetime value.
We also have to predict
the market conditions
at that point in time
because everything
keeps changing so that we
can derive the right bid
price as well.
So all these models need to work
together sometimes in tandem
and then we still have to meet
the 20 millisecond latency.
So that's the crux of
technical challenge
that we're dealing with.
And so we use a few--
we learned a few lessons
by working in this industry
long enough and then
creating values.
So for example, we are using a
relatively shallow DNN model,
so it's not that deep.
And we realize that unlike
natural language processing
or image processing,
these inferences that we
make for this
advertisement businesses
doesn't need to be
that deep, but we still
use a lot of features.
So it's shallow, but very,
very wide models that we use.
And it's OK for us to spend
a lot more time and resources
for training these big
but shallow models,
but the inference needs
to be done very quickly.
That's why we're
using shallow models.
We're using a lot of other big
data processing technologies
to reduce our response
time as much as possible,
but I guess that probably
requires another session.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Wow.
Those are some
impressive numbers--
at least, I think they are.
Was it a challenge building
something to handle all that?
How did you scale up?
CHANG KIM: Yeah.
So the scale is indeed a
big challenge here as well.
So the number of bid requests
that we receive from the ad
exchanges, that's
already astounding
because we're
receiving multimillion
requests every
second, which leads up
to about 300 billion
requests every single day.
Compared to what NYSE
deals with, for example,
they handle about 2.4
transactions every single day.
We're already two orders of
magnitude larger than that,
so you can imagine how big and
large this infrastructure is
in general, and that's because
the phones are just pervasive.
It's just so ingrained
with our lives
and then there
are so many people
using these all the
time, so we're really
handling huge
scale, for example,
more than 10 billion devices
reached through our system
every month.
We're actually serving
the ad inventories
coming out of about three
million unique publishing apps.
We're doing our ad
campaigns over 250 countries
around the world.
And then the number
of ad impressions,
the actual advertisement
shown to the end
users, that's more than
20 billion impressions
every month.
And then every single
second we're actually
running more than 15
million model inferences.
So this scale is the
biggest challenge
along with the
strict time latency
that we have to
abide by as well.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So two
really big challenges.
You've got a latency
challenge; you
have to make a lot of
responses very, very quickly.
And you have a big
data challenge;
creating and processing
all of that data every day
for your data science and
machine learning pipelines.
Wow.
I am really excited to
dive into the architecture
of all of this.
How did you make the
magic of ad serving
happen with all of that
data on top of Google Cloud?
CHANG KIM: We see advertisement
campaign commissions
from our advertisers directly
through the front end
or through API.
We receive their
request and then
we create the internally this
thing called campaign data
structures, along with
the actual creatives
that the customer has
created to show their end
customers or the device users.
And creatives are really the
image files or video files
or the texts that are shown
as part of the advertisement,
right?
So this builds the core
campaign structure.
Then these are
stored on Datastore,
Google managed Datastore
system because this
requires SQLite access as well.
And then on the
other end, we keep
receiving these bid requests,
huge number of bid requests,
through the ad exchanges so
we have a dedicated system
called the bid processor.
It's running on top of
GKE and then at the peak
we run, I don't know, thousands
of containers per region
to keep sustaining
this input rate.
So when we receive
this bid processor,
each bid we then need to
choose a few campaigns
or a large number
of campaigns that we
need to evaluate against.
Basically we need to
make a decision, OK,
for this bid request, basically
for this particular user using
this device at
this point in time
with this kind of content and
context, which of our campaigns
are good matches?
So we have to do that
prediction using machine
learning technologies.
So that's done through
our custom TensorFlow
serving infrastructure running
on top of the GKE containers
as well.
Then when you run this
model inference, of course
you need to extract
a lot of data
about the user and
then the current status
of the user, which we
call context information.
And the user's profile,
that's all public information
collected through
various channels.
And then our previous
bid history--
because the chances
that we might
have served this user
for our campaigns many,
many, many times
before, so we wanted
to learn from our previous
bidding histories as well.
So we collect all
this data stored
in BigTable and BigQuery.
So we read these things out from
BigTable and BigQuery very fast
and then handle some
of these things,
process them, and then turn
them into the right feature set
for machine learning
models and then feed them
into the TensorFlow serving.
OK?
So that's what's
happening at the bid time.
And then when we decide to
respond to the bid request,
we generate a bid response
and then send it back
to the ad exchanges.
Now when we win
this, the exchanges
let us know that, OK,
now you won this ad spot.
Why don't you actually
show the result?
So the result is shown
through the CDN service.
And then when the user,
the mobile phone user
actually responds to
this, the response
signals also come
directly sometimes to us
or sometimes through these
umpires, as I mentioned,
the MMPs.
So these impression
signals, click signals,
and further engagement
signals are collected and then
come back to us and then we
collect all these signals
through our notification
processors and event
processors.
These are important
not just because we
need to properly
generate our billing
record for our
customers, but also
to collect the data so that we
can keep training our models.
All these transactions
that we do
are just great training
examples for our models,
so that's really, really
critical infrastructure, again,
collecting this
feedback, then we
have to keep these
things in the same place
so we use BigTable again
a lot and then BigQuery
a lot for that.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So it seems
like that bit processor is sure
doing a lot of work.
How big is the Kubernetes
cluster that you need to run
and how do you make it scale?
CHANG KIM: Good question.
The short answer is we're
relying-- finally now
just relying on purely just
GKE scaling feature set.
Our bid processor is the
biggest set of containers.
Of course, we have many
others, but let's just
talk about the bid
processor alone.
It is using about two and a
half K nodes at the peak time
for processing
incoming bid requests
and it keeps increasing
our business grows.
Then initially we started off
with our in-house scalar system
to manage the
cluster for a while,
but then recently we
evaluated GKEs native scalars,
a few of them, and then realize
that just relying on strictly
those is actually better now.
So we're using just horizontal
pod scalar and cluster
autoscaler offered by GCP now.
MAX SALTONSTALL: OK, let's
talk about the data little bit.
You said 170 terabytes
being generated every day.
How do you store
that, process that,
use it for your
training and analysis?
CHANG KIM: So as I said, we keep
receiving these bid requests
and then all the follow up
signals from the ad exchanges
about our bid results
and also directly
from the mobile devices about
the impressions and so on.
So all this huge amount
of data arrived, again,
at our infrastructure
through GCPs load balancer
and then we store them
in BigTable, sometimes
the raw data and GCS
because sometimes we
have to replay them.
And then if it's very
structured and then
if it needs to be handled
by our data scientists,
we also store some of
them in BigQuery as well.
So we're probably one of the
biggest BigTable users of GCP
right now and all these
raw data are stored here
scattered at various platforms,
and then we read them out
for two purposes.
One for training and second
for analysis by human.
OK?
So for training, we actually
created a huge number
of data flow jobs so that we can
read these things out and then
turn them into the machine
learning feature sets, which
we then feed into our
Kubeflow running on our VMs.
And then these are actually
finally getting into--
when we finish
training our models,
some models are trained
hourly, some models daily,
some models a little
less frequently,
but whenever we end up
finishing our models properly,
then we load them onto
our custom TensorFlow
serving infrastructure
which is integrated
into our online
bidding infrastructure,
which I already explained.
So that's one data flow part.
And then the other part, our
engineers and data scientists
continuously need
to look up this data
to see whether we're heading in
the right direction, whether we
can improve something,
or whether the market
situation-- the macro situation
have changed significantly
that warrants our model update
or significant model redesigns
or insertion of new
models and so on.
So that pipeline
is typically done
through the online
analysis tools.
We're a big user of the
Looker system as well.
So Looker running
on top of BigQuery
is a big data processing
pipeline for us as well.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
And tell me more,
how is data flow
helping you move
all of this data around
given the immense scale
of your platform?
CHANG KIM: Yeah.
Data flow really reads data
out of BigTable, BigQuery,
and Google Cloud Storage,
and then transforms them
into feature sets.
The easy integration with
BigTable and BigQuery
was both in terms
of region, right?
That was a big motivator
for us to try this out.
We run over 1,300 data
flow jobs every day
and then process, as
I said, more than 170
terabyte every single day.
And the largest data flow job
that we have currently uses
up to about 7,000
virtual CPU hour per job,
and so that's very
CPU intensive.
We also use data
flow service space
shuffling a lot for performance
gains these days too.
MAX SALTONSTALL: What led you
to choose BigTable for storage?
CHANG KIM: It gives a very
good latency and throughput
at the same time.
The key value region writes
over 10,000 QPS at less than--
I didn't know, or 6 or 7
millisecond when we use,
especially SSD nodes.
That's just so fast
and scalable as well.
We're handling about 220
megabytes per second.
The throughput is
also great and then
the embedded garbage
collection system or capability
is also quite helpful because
we can just automatically
forget all data without
worrying about or purging
any of those things.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
That is definitely
a lot of data processing and
a large number of requests.
So how do you
optimize all of this
so that you can keep
costs under control?
CHANG KIM: The challenge
is that our scale keeps
growing significantly
and yet, your OPEX
needs to be contained.
So for example, last
two years our scale
has grown more than 3x.
So in terms of number
of bid requests
that we receive as well as
the number of bid responses
that we generate,
both more than 3x.
So in terms of bid
responses we're
now handling or generating
more than 700 billion responses
every single month.
But we track, for
example, our unit cost.
So for example, with one unit
dollar, how many bid responses
are we able to generate?
That's, for example,
one metric that we
use to measure our efficiency.
So that cost efficiency has been
slightly going up last year,
but then we realized that,
well, we had to contain that.
So we actually decide to spend
a lot of engineering resources,
optimization resources by
taking advantage of a lot of GCP
capabilities as well.
So it has started
to come down and it
looks a little more stable now.
And then some of the
key technologies,
GKE native scalars
are helping us
a lot because we can scale
in and out very easily.
And then we also now use
more diverse types of nodes,
even including preemptible VMs.
So those things are
all very helpful.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That's great.
So why did you end up choosing
Google Cloud for this platform
that you built?
CHANG KIM: Pay as
you go pricing helped
us bootstrap our business.
Even when we were
very, very small,
we were able to start growing
our business very easily
by just simply writing on
top of very big and reliable
general purpose cloud.
Operationally we also couldn't
afford to have a big ops team.
Our dev team had to
just focus on delivering
the right infrastructure code
and then the right ML models
and serving improv,
training improv,
so we started off with
very lean operations team.
Now we are a little bigger, but
I would say that more than 80%,
70% of our operations are
offloaded to the GCP team
thanks to their capabilities
and responsiveness,
so that's always a big help.
Stack Overflow is very helpful
as well because GCP engineers
regularly monitor it.
And then there are a few other
specific things that we really
enjoyed on top of GCP, like
data flow service space
shuffling and BigTable's
latency optimization
using SSDs, and then
BigQuery SQL performance
improvement over time, then
integration with Looker and BI.
Those things have been
super helpful as well.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Thank you, Chang,
very much for joining us
and sharing a lot of insight
into how and why you built
this ad serving platform
on top of Google Cloud.
That is so cool.
I now understand a lot
better how those ads show up
on my screen, what it takes
to build a very latency
sensitive, high performance
ads platform on Google Cloud,
and maybe a little bit more
about the immense power of some
of these tools.
If you liked what you saw,
please like and subscribe,
and check out the
playlist Architecting
with Google Cloud for
more videos like these.
Thanks for joining us.